suit up and hold onto your heads because
we have the second scariest Frank on
Netflix next to this guy there is but
one rule hunt or be hunted with less
than a week until the release of the new
season of The Punisher I thought it'd be
fun to see where we left off in season 1
and explain what really happened in that
bloody finale season 1 ended with an
absolutely brutal fight between Frank
Castle aka The Punisher and best friend
turned backstabbing [ __ ]
Billy Russo nice that's a knife Frank
ultimately gains the upper hand and
rather than kill Billy shoves his face
into shards of glass so that he can live
with the reminder of the pain he's
caused in the trailer for season 2 it
looks like he'll definitely be back but
that choice to let someone evil like
Billy live is a new one for Frank and
it's important in understanding Frank as
a character and where you might be
heading into season 2 the entire season
Frank goes on and on about how he'll
kill anyone who gets in his way
but with Billy he doesn't go through
with it the most evil of them all and he
doesn't do it to understand this
decision we have to go all the way back
to episode 1 in episode 1 Frank is in a
dark place reeling from the death of his
family using a secret alias living in a
shitty apartment and constantly harassed
by his fellow construction co-workers
who call him a [ __ ]
Frank is lost unsure what life has in
store for him rattled by grief with no
will to live he even keeps his head down
trying not to get involved with
potential new friends like Donnie
because everyone he gets close to seems
to die and what better metaphor to show
the barriers Frank needs to overcome
than a concrete wall the wall is his
guilt the belief that he was responsible
for the death of his wife and children
we see him violently chip away at it to
the point where his hands become a
bloody mess his last name Castle alludes
to the impenetrable walls of medieval
castles but instead of keeping out
foreign invaders for Frank it's the pain
and emotions guilt is one of the biggest
themes this season almost every
character has some form of it Frank for
the death of his family and also how he
treated his son in a flashback he
laments how he scolded his son on a
ferry ride and when his son was younger
chastised him for drawing it
of a marine on the wall not realizing he
drew it because he wanted to be just
like his dad he also feels responsible
for Kurtis losing his leg he couldn't
shoot the pregnant woman who had a bomb
in Afghanistan which led to the loss of
it the name The Punisher not only
relates to how Frank treats his victims
but how he treats himself he is punished
every day by the memory of his dead
family it haunts him other characters
such as David Lieberman aka Mike Rowe
who ends up joining Frank and his
crusade feels the guilt of not being
there for his family the torture of
watching them without being with them is
a common thread throughout the season
David's wife Sarah drinks copious
amounts of wine during the day to cover
the guilt she has over not being able to
manage her children you're not gonna
judge me for appreciating little Rosie
her son she even finds carrying a knife
around in his backpack
a plot point which ends up leading to
one of the most interesting and
emotional scenes in the season
officer Deena Madani has guilt over the
death of her partner Sam Stein who was
killed by Billy Russo on a fake decoy op
that was entirely her plan but the
person who doesn't show any signs of
guilt at all you guessed it Billy Russo
in fact he's pretty remorseless the
writers even added scenes that
technically do not add to the plot at
all just to flesh out how evil this guy
is for example in episode 8 we find out
that Billy has his heroin addict mother
tied to the hospital bed to live in
torment for the rest of her life he's a
keeper Madani Frank is equally ruthless
but what differentiates him from Billy
is that he has a code he kills only the
bad and isn't interested in power or
money like Billy's take how the two of
them approach situations in which they
need to escape in episode 7 when Frank
flees from the military base he's
stopped by a young soldier instead of
just taking him out Frank warns him
he doesn't want to hurt him contrast
that to Billy who completely goes on a
rampage when leaving anvil to fight
Frank but everything comes to a head
when Frank and Billy faceoff at the
Carousel the same location Frank's
family was brutally murdered and Billy
knows this this trauma PTSD if you will
will give billion upper-hand since Frank
must not only fight Billy but his own
Demon's if he's going to win the day and
the carousel is personified by Frank
himself both go around in circles it
never goes anywhere just round and round
it's usually a symbol of youth and
innocence there are even two young
employees who are tied up as hostages
but here the carousel is one of blood
and violence after the vicious battle
between Frank and Billy Frank lets Billy
lives stating Gigi this whole season has
culminated in this decision
Frank has learned that the pain of
living with lofts far outweighs the easy
way out of killing yourself the pain of
waking up and looking for your loved
ones only to be reminded that they are
dead is a hell in and of itself so he
decides to completely tear apart Billy's
face as a reminder of him in fact this
notion of him being a reminder is
brought up in episode 12 after being
brought to the brink of death Frank
experiences visions of himself and his
wife she encourages him to come with her
which would mean his death but Frank
decides to push through dying is the
coward's way out he must fight and after
he kills Rawlins he proclaims that he
will live on as a reminder on the other
hand we have Billy who pleads with Frank
to kill him he'd rather die than live
and be reminded of what Frank did to him
but Frank knows it would be worse for
Billy to let him live that is his
punishment as he says in episode three
people tainted or Jewish Payne's not be
it's done it's time slowly realize that
your life itself he wants Billy to live
in this torture what this show does well
is slowly create change in Frank it
doesn't happen like a flip of a switch
he has to see for himself the error of
his worldview before he can truly change
my favourite example of this is when
Frank teaches David's son a lesson by
holding a knife to his neck
ah good father/son talk we learned the
reason the kid had the knife in the
first place was that he was lonely and
sad and that he wanted to make others
feel bad like he does what better mirror
to hold up to Frank who essentially does
the same thing and mirrors are often
symbols of confronting our inner selves
like the mirrors both Billy and Frank
look into at the carousels mirrors which
Frank avoids in episode 1 but must
confront in episode 13 he's really look
in the mirror you get it yeah you gotta
admit who you are but not just to
yourself you could be and everybody else
so while the Punisher may be a
shoot-'em-up action extravaganza it's
also the story of a man struggling with
grief trying to overcome loss and move
on because if you don't you'll just end
up on that carousel round and round
until it's too late thanks everyone for
watching I got a whole bunch more stuff
than we have here the end of January and
I'm hoping to do an analysis of season
two so make sure you're subscribed with
the Belon to get my latest videos
we're almost at 100k so a huge thank you
to everyone
and remember daddy loves you very much